Since whimsy has been born,
I've been struggling with my eczema so bad.
It usually starts on my palms,
which have been really inflamed lately.
Always make sure to take my seed DSO one symbiotic,
especially when I'm feeling extra stressed.
My eczema is flaring up. We have a lot of travel coming up.
There's always a direct link between my gut health and my skin,
so I know that when my gut health is off,
my skin is probably gonna be off in vice versa.
Also, with a lot of travel coming up,
I wanna make sure my immune system is as strong as it can be.
This is a 24 strain probiotic blend.
I usually take two capsules before my breakfast every morning.
If you're dealing with eczema,
skin issues, bloating,
low immune function,
it's definitely worth it looking into getting a probiotic.